[Music]
let's switch it up now talk a little bit
of Megan Marco live in that royal rises
on Saturday she celebrated her first
birthday as a duchess made quite the
style statement in the process the
Duchess celebrated her 37th wearing a
$328 color-block dress from The Canadian
brand Club Monaco her sky-high aquaszero
stilettos actually cost more than double
the price of her dress she and Harry
attended the wedding of his longtime pal
Charlie then Straub and zi2 videographer
desi Jenks the Prince rushed into the
church by himself he was in the wedding
party so maybe he had some duties to
attend to but Megan had a bit of a
wardrobe malfunction her lacy dark Brock
peeked out but she even made that look
stylish and it seems Megan's family feud
continues our royal source says she
remains upset with her father for giving
interviews to the press about her this
weekend her half sister Samantha Markel
posted angry Twitter rants comparing
Megan to a Disney villainess tweeting
quote okay so Cruella Deville is
retreating LOL let me know how that
works out for you in another she said
any father out there knows that this is
wrong snap out of it Witchiepoo
Witchiepoo was a character in the
sixties children's show HR Pufnstuf
meanwhile megan is looking forward to
some royal R&R with Harry's family at
Balmoral Castle in Scotland William Kate
and the kids are also expected to spend
some vacay time at the Queen's 50,000
acre estate
you
[Music]
[Applause]